so what is FGM it's very simply the
removal of a girl's external genitals
the clitoris the labia and in severe
cases the wound that's left is so not so
there's only a tiny hole left it's done
simply to control women it predates
religion it's not done for religious
purposes parents do it because they feel
that their daughters will then be
married they don't do it just to inflict
pain on them and it's an incredibly
difficult social issue that has to be
changed through talking with communities
and what you're seeing there is the most
intensive form which is called
infibulation you can see the impact this
is going to have basically you're
closing up and sealing the entire
genitals what happens as a result is
that a woman's virginity is ensured that
she will remain chaste so her husband
knows that fidelity won't be an issue
it's a very very complex issue yet it's
also very straightforward
you